(shoes squeaking)
(dark rock music)
- I just need to get on the
record that this is rust.
This is a week long rust,
for some two week long,
that's why everything
you're getting on tape
right now is trash.
It's absolute trash.
The missed buckets,
we missed our foul shots.
- Well except for the time that
I got Gary on the no look pass.
- [Rami] That was pretty good.
- That was good.
- Just for the record.
Just for the record.
- [Gary] Fuck!
- [DRock] Morning.
- Morning.
- [DRock] How do you feel?
- Back.
We're fucking back, DRock.
(light music)
- [Gary] Okay.
It's great to see everybody.
How was your New Year's?
- [Marcus] It was good.
- [Gary] Great.
Good, really good.
I really did rest.
You're absolutely right, Claude.
I took a look at like my first
four months calendar like the
third day in and
I was like, "Okay,
"I'm gonna rest 'cause I don't
know when it's gonna happen."
Antigua was great.
(crosstalk)
Oh, I'm sorry.
No, it was Anguilla.
It was Anguilla.
I didn't go to Antigua.
I went to Anguilla.
It was great.
It was originally The Viceroy
but then it was bought
by the Four Seasons.
It was great
except that we got there
super late the first day,
and the second day I was
only awake for four hours.
Like completely, yeah.
Like slept in,
woke up 10 o'clock.
Had a massage at
like 10:30, had lunch,
drank like three-fourths
of a bottle of wine and
went to sleep at 4:30.
And didn't wake up until 9 A.M.
the next day.
- [Man] #Blessed.
- It was the best.
- [Tyler] Did
those fire up there?
- What? The case does it.
- It should just be
connected to your phone.
Wes Reynolds you know about Wes?
- Alright. So, this is it?
(DRock laughs)
This is the new shit?
- [Tyler] Yeah.
- [Gary] Hey guys.
How are you?
Where's your name tag,
Cor?
That's a really
fucking funny thing.
That's such a good clip.
- [AJ] Ready to go?
- Yep.
- [AJ] 'Sup, DRock?
I'm so tired.
(DRock laughs)
I'm so spent from
basketball my legs are dead.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- [Tyler] My back.
- [Jon] How's it goin'?
- [Gary] Really well, my friend.
Such a pleasure.
Is this a surreal feeling?
- Yeah.
- [Brian] Got his
Combine invite yesterday.
- [Woman] That was a big deal.
- [AJ] Back to Indy.
- What do you want to work on?
Have you given that thought?
- In terms of what?
- [Gary] For the Combine?
Have you thought about that?
- I was thinking I want to
work a lot more just skill
development on the
field kind of stuff.
Just lineman type stuff.
- [Gary] Mhmmm.
- Just to kinda--
- [Gary] Technique.
- [Brian] His positional
coach is Jon Stinchcomb.
- [Gary] Mhmmm.
What about the interviews?
- Interviews are big.
- To me, that's where
you're gonna explode.
- Mhmmm and that's
working with Chip and John.
- [Gary] Thank you so much
for the opportunity, man.
- Yeah. It's good meeting you.
- [Gary] I'm really excited.
- [Jon] Yeah.
- [Gary] Thank you.
Such a pleasure.
- Pleasure meeting you.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- Thank you, so much.
- [Gary] If I can be a help
in any way please let me know.
Jon, yep, I see it.
- [Jon Sr.] You're wired.
- [Gary] I'm wired.
It's a real pleasure.
Thank you so much.
I think we do but I need to
wrap my head around it first.
- [Tyler] Cool.
Higgins tomorrow.
- [Gary] Yeah, exactly.
What do they need?
The details of their deal?
- [Steve] Hey guys, how are you?
- [Gary] Really well, man.
How are you? Happy New Year.
- [Steve] Happy New Year.
Okay, so we're starting the
new year off with some news,
I see.
- [Gary] Yes, a little news.
- [Steve] So I saw the details
you guys sent over a little
earlier but maybe the best
place to start would be just so
I understand exactly what the
structure is so this is sort of
a separate to VaynerMedia.
It'll be sort of the
publisher side of sort of
a new holding company.
Is that kind of right, Gary?
- That's right, Steve.
- [Steve] Okay.
- It's not owned by Vayner, it's
a sister company to it that is
gonna be called The Gallery.
As a matter of fact if even
think about how I named the
company from the
beginning, VaynerMedia,
it was always the ambition from
Day 1 to try to be involved if
we were able to
execute over the next two,
three decades in all facets
as I thought what the
internet was going to do.
And I think the reason that the
most macro level for why it's
happening, Steve, is I think
the internet itself creates an
infrastructure that allows
people to be involved in a lot
of things at once and so--
- [Steve] Right.
- so to me five
or six years ago,
this became very obvious to me
and so we just needed to get big
enough and I bought small little
media sites along the way.
Fooled around with it like we
finally got to place where we
could afford and make
a proper play for the,
you know, I think for me I'm a
big fan of the jockey
along with the horse.
- [Steve] Right.
- And so, you know
over the half decade,
seven years getting to know
Ryan and you know on and
off the field
using a sports term.
And so,--
- [Steve] Yeah.
- I'm really, to be very honest,
it's a very important day in
the history of my career because
I think it's a foray at a major
level into the media side and
that's why we formed The Gallery
because I think the
ambition is obviously,
pure as a real thing and we
have real work to do and we have
aspirations for it to be
as big as possible and
as impactful as possible.
But it is structured
and at the highest level,
the goal is to be as successful
as possible in producing the
stories that grab people's
attention at the highest levels
for every demo,
forever at the, just like,
I want to buy the
New York Jets, Steve.
Good New Year?
- Great New Year.
- [Woman 2] Lovely.
- [Gary] Approve it.
Damn it.
Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 236 of the
The #AskGaryVee Show.
- [Carlos] My question is when
you are setting up a start up,
this is a pricing question.
Would you go strictly
trying to compete?
How do you get that start
up number if you're offering
services or a product?
Just go try to be
cheaper with the competition?
If you have a better product?
What's you're thought on that?
- Yes.
(silence)
Do you understand?
- [Carlos] Yeah.
- If you are building a business
that you want to build and you
want to support your life and
family and have all the riches
that entrepreneurship requires
well then you need
to spend 18 hours a day...
Is it a good idea to
have a better product?
Yes.
Is it a good idea to have a
service at a lower price than
your competitors to give
the person that is actually
financially conscious the
ability to go with you?
Yes.
Is it better for you to cold
call 97 people versus six?
Yes.
Is it better for you to produce
great content that reaches
people through virality that is
better than your competition so
they know about your service?
Yes.
Is it better to hit up your
grandfather 'cause he's friends
with this guy who's got a
business in the space that
you're trying to reach?
Yes.
Is it better to put your phone
number on Instagram Live to get
on The #AskGaryVee
Show to get an answer?
Yes.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] That's awesome.
And how's it been going here?
- [Man 2] Everything's
been going well, you know.
- How do you like the culture?
- [Man 2] I like it a lot.
- Yeah.
- [Man 2] Yeah.
Everything's been good so far.
- Good, man.
- [Francisco] How's it going?
- [Gary] Hey!
Good to see you, man.
- Nice to see you, too.
- What's going on?
- Not much.
- How was your
holiday, Francisco?
- It was good,
it was relaxing actually.
I didn't do much.
Sat by a fireplace
every single day.
- Dude, that's good.
You know,
honestly, I had a very,
I didn't sit by a fireplace
but theoretically I did.
I didn't do shit.
I really didn't.
- [Francisco] Felt good to
sort of unwind a little bit.
- How you doin'?
- [Francisco] I'm doing well.
I'm doing well.
- Good, man.
What's been going on?
So how long you been here now?
- [Francisco] I started
June 6th.
- Yep.
- [Francisco] So six months.
- Lot of different
things have happened.
- [Francisco] Yeah.
- In your guys' department
since you been here.
Let's start this way,
how do you feel today?
- [Francisco] I feel good.
I like the company a lot.
- [Gary] How do you doin'?
- Good.
- [Gary] How's work?
- Great.
- [Gary] Good. Tell me.
- People I'm working
with are the best.
Very, very happy with
who I ended up with.
- [Gary] Yeah, you
ended up with an A-team.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] That's the truth.
- Everybody I work
with is unbelievable.
- [Gary] Yeah.
What was it?
Your spirit animal was
originally not an owl.
- [Zach] I was in a dilemma.
I love zebras.
I'm obsessed with owls.
- [Gary] Have you
ever heard of Wuzzles?
- [Zach] Wuzzles?
- Wuzzles.
- [Zach] No.
- So something I like to
reference once in a while
that's why DRock's laughing.
It was a 1980s cartoon for like
three seasons and it was the
combination of two animals.
- [Zach] You know
what's funny about that?
In interviews I ask,
it's the last question,
kind of how funny are you?
If you can combine
any two animals,
what would it be?
And if they're a designer,
make them draw it.
- [Gary] That's cool.
- And we collaborate.
So, it would be a
zebra-owl if I could.
- [Gary] Yeah but you got to
come up with a better name.
- Oh yeah, totally.
- [Gary] Like Owl-bra.
Owl-bra!
- [Zach] Owl-bra.
- Owl-bra.
- [Zach] I'll draw it for you.
- Jessica Owl-bra.
(group laughter)
- But it's so interesting to see
how far the company's gone
on the execution level.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- And how many people
can just collaborate when
you have that scale.
- [Gary] Yes.
- That size.
And I've just found that so
intriguing that we've been able
to maintain that ability--
- [Gary] Yep.
- 'cause it's super hard.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- The down, man, what's a con?
Honestly,
it's hard to keep
up with everyone.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- Before, like this,
I'm glad we did that--
- [Gary] Yeah.
- because we're in our weekly
meeting and Kenny and I were
like ooh, old school
Vayner coming back.
These are the things that--
- [Gary] Matter.
- will bring people closer.
- [Gary] 100%.
- I walked down the
hallway and it's barely
"Oh, you know, hey,"--
- [Gary] Yeah.
- barely interact with
them but it's not as hard to
give them a high five, right?
'Cause Joe Whitmarsh
and I back in the day,--
- [Gary] 100%.
- if you didn't give
someone a high five,
it's like, "Are you okay?"
- [Gary] You got kicked out.
- Yeah.
Like what's going on?
- [Gary] Yeah.
- So, that's been
interesting to see.
- [Gary] Actually,
you know what?
I'm gonna send a
companywide email right now.
Let me see your tag,
I'm gonna use it as a prox.
Use it as a prop.
Cool. Cool.
- [Zach] Yeah.
But it's been crazy, man.
Being back.
- [Gary] I'm so happy
you're back, man.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Hit me up any
time if you need anything.
- Yeah, totally.
- Awesome, man.
- DRock.
- [DRock] Later.
- Take care.
In the same reverse no B.S.
we have know plenty of our
shortcomings and everybody's got
strengths and weaknesses,
I just know every organization
stems from the top.
We actually want to do
it for the right reasons.
I've never had,
I've never made a decision,
I run this company,
that is predicated on our
personal financial situation.
- [Woman 2] Which is unheard of.
- Unheard of.
It only happens, it's not
'cause I'm Mother Teresa,
it only happens 'cause I'm so
capable of growing top line
revenue so it hides
all the mistakes.
- [Woman 2] Mhmmm.
- Because I myself can get us
so much new business it's just
enables us to actually try to
figure it out in a time when
it's being figured out.
Like everything's changing.
- [Woman 2] Yeah.
- And that's cool.
You know, one thing that people,
so when I started talking about
this whole world 10 years ago,
so many creatives pooh-poohed it
'cause they think it's small.
They still think it's small.
This is now 10 years later
but I remember thinking wow,
they're so blind.
These creatives don't realize
that 96% of creatives don't
become Steven Spielberg
or anything close to it
and then their
stuff is never seen.
How can you be a creative?
I believe that as a far more
creative person than people
realize, I believe in it so much
that I'm documenting it daily
and putting it out the next day.
How would you want to
work on television?
Like when I met Jason, the
reason I knew he was my guy
is the passion
oozing out of his eyes.
Was like I can't work on another
TV show like the last four in a
row that don't see
the day of life.
Like how can you work for
four years as a creative telling
stories and it never be seen?
- [Woman 2] Exactly.
- It's insane.
More people saw that Budweiser
video on Facebook than like 94%
of the content on television.
- I feel like there's definitely
a place for me to grow--
- [Gary] 100%.
- and do what I want to do.
It's really great to be here and
to have this time with you and
not what I was expecting the day
back in the office but I'm happy
to see your face.
- [Gary] I'm glad.
- This one-on-one time and
just to grow with the company.
- It's great to see you.
- [Woman 2] You too.
Thank you so much.
- [Gary] Talk to you soon.
- [Woman 2] Thank you,
my friend. Take care.
- [DRock] Bye.
(light music)
- Gary, how are you?
- [Gary] Awesome.
Oh, we're here?
We did this.
It's so cool.
- [Brian] Yeah, it
was a great idea.
- [Gary] Looking good.
- [Gary] There we go.
(group cheer and applause)
- [Jon Sr.] Now you
get to eat the shard.
- Show your toughness.
- [Gary] Awesome, thank you.
Guys, just so you know,
VaynerSports is going to
literally be a major player.
The two kids that
we just signed.
This kid Toth that's in there,
gonna be second round center.
He's gonna be All-Pro center.
Just money in the bank
if he stays healthy.
He's the best
center in the draft.
I want to be very involved
in the first 7 to
10 pitches, 15 even.
Show you some of the moves that
I think are gonna
work in that world.
I need to hear it so
I can reverse engineer it.
We're gonna be
very entrepreneurial.
Here comes
(censored) and he's like,
"Wait a minute, we have
700 employees if you count,"
"No, no."
Obviously, we're not
gonna, the answer is to,
the thing to do here.
- [Man 3] Say yes.
- Correct.
The goal here is, you know,
to really think about how to
position this because if
we position it properly,
I can get loud and
if I can get loud
we'll have unlimited deal flow.
We'll just close
people left and right.
- Hey.
- [Eric] How you doin'?
- All good stuff, man.
How are you?
- [Eric] Doing awesome, brother.
How was your vacation?
- Really good.
Super checked out and
just spent mainly
time on just hacking
Instagram and just
relaxing so it was good.
Listen, there's two things
I'd like to accomplish
in this meeting.
One, is to talk about
the content around you.
Are we gonna do a DailyVee or we
gonna do an #AskGaryVee and how
much you're the franchise man.
Obviously, you have with
Lindsay and I've been talking.
Do we do both?
What do we do?
How does that work out in the
(censored)-thousand dollar
kind of fee thing?
And then, number two,
Jon's been working
with KT, right?
You know, this conversation of
classic like everybody has to
deal with this which I just need
clarity from you of your point
of view versus your
CFO's point of view of
like what should we deal with.
And by the way
I want you to know,
Eric, nothing scares me.
I just want to get to the
clarity of it so we can tell you
what we can
deliver for what, right?
Are you interested in
being followed around from a
day-to-day standpoint or two,
three times a week DailyVee?
Do you want to redo what you
were gonna do anyway where like
maybe it's a once a week show
where we actually go and find
franchisees and do
something like that?
Podcasts?
Where do you, what pillar of
creative are you thinking?
(light music)
Let's get this all wrapped up
and then we'll talk soon.
- [Eric] Alright, Gary. Bye.
- Talk to you.
- [Eric] Thanks, brother.
- Alright, bye-bye.
- I mean...
- [Trouty] So...
- That's small business,
by the way.
There's a lot more of those.
It all comes back to the
way I built Wine Library.
When I get in the wine business,
everybody sold Opus One
for $110 but it cost $63.
So, I just sold it for $69.99.
Market share capture.
Also allows us to
do some, you know,
we have clients that want to
give us media dollars but can't.
It's a way to play with dollars.
- [Woman 3] Yeah,
but being very disruptive.
- [Gary] Yes.
Did you see my,
you felt my strength today.
- [Nick] I'm messed up, man.
- [Gary] You
probably ran into me.
- I'm short.
- [Gary] You ran into me.
Yeah, you know what's funny?
Honestly, and
I think you maybe felt it,
too, this is not a joke,
I'm being a little bit but
I actually, actually have
quantified the strength that
Jordan gave me based
on our interactions.
- [Nick] Because two years ago,
we'd throw you around.
And now, that's not the case.
- [Gary] There's one weird play
where we ran into each other and
I didn't see you.
- Yep.
- [Gary] And I was
thinking to myself,
"My God, 24 months ago,"--
- [Nick] Yeah.
- "I would have been dead."
- [Nick] The problem is now is
that I'm more afraid
when you're behind me.
- [Gary] Right.
- Right?
- [Gary] Because?
- I would feel okay to
back up into you before--
- [Gary] Yes.
- and now it's
quite the opposite.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- [Tyler] I just
don't give a fuck.
- [Gary] That's why
I threw you around.
See how far he flew?
- [Sid] Extra tab
that's podcasts--
- [Gary] Where?
The website?
- [Sid] On the website.
- [Gary] In.
- [Sid] For which we have
different links to the different
audio experience we have like
Stitcher and iHeartRadio
and iTunes--
- [Gary] In.
- [Sid] because--
- [Gary] In, in.
- [Sid] when you
link up the iTunes,--
- [Gary] In, in, in.
- [Sid] in about a week.
I've spoken with Zak.
- [Gary] Pumped.
That's exact, that's
good offensive work.
I like your hair, too.
That's a good move.
- [Sid] Thanks.
Got some work done today.
Lots of ups and downs.
Got to figure out how to
show more downs this year.
I'm such a positive
person in general,
and usually downs involve,
you know it's funny.
I wish that the downs didn't
involve other people so I'm
really sorry Vayner Nation that
I can't show you what a stunning
percentage of my day
is actually downs because
I'm protecting other people.
That's what's happening.
Like, you know, we're not going
to show you the entire Tyler
freak out about the
scheduling this week.
You know?
Just not gonna happen.
- I appreciate that.
(group laughter)
- But you know what I mean?
Can't protect but
there's plenty of downs.
What, she smells you?
Hey guys.
Hi. I'm good.
How are you?
- [Woman 4] Good.
Happy New Year.
- Same to you.
Was it good?
- [Woman 4] Yes.
- Enjoyed it?
- [Woman 4] I was in
Miami yesterday, so you know.
- The weather was
great in Florida, right?
- [Woman 4] It was like the
hottest it's been since like the
'70s they said.
- Yeah.
I was in Naples on
the other side--
- [Woman 4] Do you
have family down there?
- I do, my in-laws live there.
- [Woman 4] Nice.
- [Gary] 'Sup brother?
- [Man 4] Where's
your spirit animal?
- [Gary] Me. (laughs) Go.
I'm going to see
"The Color Purple."
- [Woman 5] Tonight's
the last night.
- Is tonight the last night?
- [Woman 5] Yeah, I think so.
- I'm feeling very
emotional about this.
(group laughter)
Good night, guys.
Have a great night.
- [Woman 6] Good night.
- Take care.
Hi.
Woohf!
- [DRock] Got to get
that hustle back.
I'm fine.
I'll go another 12 hours.
But yeah, there's a little bit
of when you let
your body down, yep.
(light music)